[Music]
right around 1994-95 the national
library of medicine
lost the services of a big contractor
for the manual entry of
citation data from the journal articles
which essentially meant that medline
itself
nlm's database
at the time medline itself was getting
out of date day by day and week by week
and dr lindberg recognized that that's
an untenable
situation so many people in the library
pitched in to manually enter
the data from the journal articles and
so on but he simultaneously
wanted an automated system to do that
and he came up to the 10th floor and
asked if
it can be done and of course of course
it can be done
and so we built a system that we call
mars
that has lasted 22 years
as of today and uh
this is a system that extracts
the citation data author names title and
so forth in an automated way so that
manual entry is not needed this is a
the first example as far as i can
see of machine learning
used anywhere at nih certainly at nlm
we are now today
using machine learning techniques
especially the new
deep learning models for a variety of
information extraction goals for malaria
screening or screening for tb
and the like nlm's goals
in information the
extraction the collection the
dissemination
the storage of information information
is
nlm is mirrored by
the work done in
extracting information from x-rays
or digitized glass
slides or tissue images or
or full text in books and articles
it's all extracting information for a
purpose
the listed whole center's mission in
that
regard i don't think has vanished
there is still a lot of opportunity
to establish systems that could
serve as a prototype and as an example
for others to carry on in
practical ways let's say
you